Well, look, he's everyone it's Kit
Harington. Hey, I've been having a terrible time
Thank God you're here
Actually, Emilia,
they told me to tell you to shut it down.
To shut it down.
Wrap it up.
Seriously? Yeah.
Sorry. Okay. Sorry. No.
Yes. we'll, we'll
To we'll to we'll turn the cameras off.
We'll turn it
Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie
Marvel just revealed more plans for Kit
Harington's Black Knight and Emilia Clarke in the MCU.
It involves a very deep cut British superhero team.
I know there are all kinds of questions
about the way they left both of those characters
in the last few years.
teasers that seemed like they went to nowhere.
When are they going to pay these things off?
Turns out there is a plan, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It almost feels like doing videos
for the original Game of Thrones series.
Again, with them coming together.
I am sure he will still know absolutely nothing.
She will be his queen and hopefully, hopefully
she will not go mad and he won't have to kill her.
But Marvel has been dropping a bunch of news recently
about their upcoming plans the next several years.
The way they announced stuff, though, it's
not always clear if everything's coming before Avengers
Secret Wars or after this big soft reboot
they're going to be doing for the entire MCU.
General rule of thumb with that kind of stuff
is the quieter they are about stuff like the briefer,
their teasers, the smaller they are, the further out
the projects are probably going to be.
Meaning
that this Excalibur project could be after secret wars.
but a little while ago, when Marvel was busy
hyping up its Marvel phase
five movies, TV shows,
and the really big stuff was coming before.
Avengers five, like Deadpool three.
We're about to get a trailer for that.
According to some sites,
they let slip that one of the plans they have for Kit
Harington's Black Knight
character is to use him on a British superhero team
that would also feature
Emilia Clarke Guy, a character from Secret Invasion.
turns out when Kevin Foggy was talking about the
something more that they had planned
for Kit Harington's character,
this is probably what they were talking about added.
He's a really amazing actor, and this part came up
in the Eternals film that we're doing.
We were so happy when he agreed to join,
and it is a part that could
perhaps grow into something else in the future.
originally when they posted that,
I assumed that he was talking about Avengers five.
But in the Marvel Comics, Dane Whitman
actually wasn't British.
He was from a British family.
But he was born and raised in Massachusetts,
in the United States.
So largely at the time,
he was viewed as an American character
in appeared for the first time
in classic Avengers comics.
He spent a lot of time with The Avengers
during subsequent runs in the comics to met,
when they introduced Kit Harington's
version of the character in the Eternals movie,
he was very British,
like he was working in the British History Museum.
Most people, myself included, assumed
they were just changing the character's backstory.
they would say he came from a British family
like it goes back to the original Sir
Percy Black Knight during the days of Camelot,
King Arthur of the Round Table.
But he was also raised British in Great Britain.
in that would be their way of explaining
Kit Harington's accent,
his backstory in the comics with his uncle,
who was the previous evil Black Knight
that The Avengers fought this castle where Dane
Whitman found the Ebony blade all true to the comics.
They did a version of that in the Eternals
Post-Credits scene with a couple of changes
In the comics originally,
he didn't know anything about the Ebony blade
before he found it, or about his family's heritage
and the curse of the Black Knight itself.
he just thought that he was from a rich British
family line his parents had been estranged from.
And that's why he grew up in the United States
during the Eternals movie.
He said he already knew everything
about his family history,
kind of hinted about the curse of the Black Knight,
But it sounds like in the Post-Credits scene,
the reason why he'd been estranged from his uncle
was because he had succumbed to the curse
of the ebony blade and it tore their family apart.
And this is why he was so hesitant
to pick up the blade in the Post-Credits scene,
because he knew exactly how the curse worked
and had seen it destroy its uncle.
Also probably helped that Mahershala
Ali Blade character was there off screen,
filling him in on a lot of the details.
by the way, if you're going to touch that,
it comes with a really hefty curse.
it sounds like at the time they introduced
Kit Harington's version of the character,
some of their movie,
their TV show plans were a little bit different.
Like we've seen all the changes going on
the last several years at Marvel very, very chaotic.
I've really done a bunch of videos
about how he was supposed to have a big crossover
with the new Blade character in his movie.
He was supposed to show up in Avengers five.
Some of that has probably changed, a while ago,
Marvel registered trademarks
for a bunch of different movies and TV shows,
confirming a lot of our theories.
They were developing a sense of midnight series.
I've already done a video about that.
He might have some crossover in that
with Moonlight Blade, Ghost Writer, Werewolf by Night,
Other darker characters,
because it does sound like Marvel plans on doing
that, in it turns out Excalibur would be basically
one of their other projects, like a British version
of The Avengers, the way they use them in the MCU.
we heard a while ago
that Marvel was planning on bringing Emilia
Clarke back for a bigger role after secret invasion.
There were a lot of theories about what this would be.
They had a huge teaser at the end of that series.
Your people need a leader.
You'll
need resources to fight this war
that Ritson has launched on your people.
And I can give them to you.
I will you, as you do,
you will use me and together will make this planet safe
for both our people.
Turns out this was for the Excalibur British team up.
you could just see someone at Marvel seeing Kit
Harington's picture and Emilia Clarke's picture saying,
we have to put them on
The same team is just too juicy to not do it.
right now, she's
probably the most powerful Skrull in existence, given
most of their race was killed off during the Marvel's
movie empire.
Doric did survive and they came back to New Asgard.
So like all the scrolls are on earth now,
but they kind of hate
her up as the new leader of her race,
taking over for her father.
So as long as she doesn't go mad,
doesn't have to be killed by anybody, we should be fine
there have been more and more Game of Thrones actors
showing up in Marvel the last couple of years, mostly
because the cast of that show was so big.
It went on for so long.
There's so many Marvel movies and shows right now.
It was bound to happen.
Really good Example Beric Dondarrion
also showed up at the beginning of Secret Invasion.
if Marvel is developing an Excalibur project,
it seems that they're using Sonya Falls was character
is the British Nick Fury for that team
putting them together her teams are at the end of that
had a lot of Nick Fury Iron Man Post-Credits scene
energy to it to like I'm here to put together a team
there are a lot of theories that Emilia Clarke
would actually become the MCU Captain Britain.
But right now I don't think that she will.
I think they'll just keep calling her Gaia
and anyone else on the team will start calling her
by a human nickname, they'll probably explain
more limitations to her powers
that she doesn't turn into an even bigger meme.
That was such a huge question mark
after Secret invasion.
If she has every single power
for the most part in the MCU,
Why is it
she's suddenly the most powerful character ever?
Usually on a story level,
the way they fix problems like that is to say
that her powers are extremely temporary,
with a huge cooldown.
the duration of the fight that she had
at the end of that series was about her limit.
After that, she probably couldn't use her powers
for a long time, just making her squishy in a fight.
not quite a glass cannon,
but close like short bursts of crazy power,
but then longer cooldown periods where she does
get super squishy in fights.
Otherwise she wouldn't need a team.
It'd be completely redundant.
It would even make sense.
the original Excalibur team in the comics
was a British team, but it's more of an X-Men
spin off mutant based team like stories
they get involved in were typically X-Men stories.
But here's the thing.
We're actually heading into a very X-Men mutant
heavy phase after Avengers Secret Wars.
So it just makes sense to introduce
this X-Men spinoff team in an X-Men heavy phase.
some of the MCU roster that team would have to be
a little bit different from the original roster
in the comics and I'm not sure they'll use captain
Britain but they might introduce them at some point.
Kit Harington's Black Knight
character also wasn't on that original Excalibur team,
but he does share a lot of the same mythology
as the other British characters.
mostly in Merlin.
Morgan Levey The Black Knights origins
go back to Camelot, Knights of the Round Table,
The King Arthur Chronicles,
which is a big crossover point for the Excalibur team.
they even introduced the Excalibur sword
during the Eternals movie, including Kit
Harington's, Black Knight, the Ebony Blade.
They explained the Eternals
lived in actual Camelot for a brief period in the UK
during that part of history,
revealing that Camelot was a real place in the MCU.
Merlin, who created the Ebony Blade, was a real person.
He was probably the sorcerer supreme of his era.
some of that starts to get into multiverse
territory, too, like Merlin, becomes
more of a multiverse character,
like a multiverse version of Doctor Strange.
Morgan, let's say, for example, was a real sorceress
who, in present day is actually supposed
to be played by Aubrey Plaza
during the Agatha Coven of Chaos episodes.
She's a huge Excalibur villain.
the earlier teaser for Captain
Britain went back to Avengers Endgame.
I talked about this
when the movie came out a couple of years ago.
You probably remember, which was them basically
saying that they were doing the character at some point
when Captain America goes back to the 1970s
with Iron Man during the time heist, he's inside
Peggy Carter's office.
And here's her mention.
Agent Braddock is out on a mission
now this is meant to be the 1970s, remember?
So I'm assuming that it'd be Brian Braddock's
either parents or his ancestor at some point
because Brian Braddock is a multiverse character,
he does jump around time and space.
It could have also been a version
of Brian Braddock in this scene.
But that's meant to be his real name.
He is Brian Braddock.
He's kind of like the British version
of Captain America, even though his origin story
and his powers are completely different.
This is the way the people view him.
Like, if you're not a big comic book, then you see him,
you see, Oh, it's kind of like British Captain
America In reality, he's
completely different from Captain America,
for those who either want to see
Henry Cavill show up in the MCU.
That actually be a pretty solid pick for him because,
for instance, he's not going to play the century.
The century is kind of like Marvel's
version of a more sinister
bent Superman, like a crazy version of Superman
But you can see how Marvel is trying to introduce more
and more of their British characters just in general.
if Marvel does introduce Excalibur
with Kit Harington, Emilia Clarke coming back,
which other characters
would you want to be on that inaugural team?
Keep in mind,
we're probably going to have a bunch of mutants
everywhere when the team eventually would show up.
So pretty much anybody from the comics is fair
game to be on that.
Speaking of mutants, we're going to get a brand new
Deadpool three trailer pretty soon at the Super Bowl.
Whatever they wind up releasing,
of course, I will do a video for it.
Hopefully, Ryan Reynolds,
Hugh Jackman will do something completely crazy.
I just did a video for the brand new teaser
that Ryan Reynolds dropped.
Click here for that.
It's ridiculous, as you would expect, and click here
to learn about all the defenders characters
that Marvel just announced are coming back
during Daredevil Born Again.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!